bonjour à tous j'ai très heureux d'être
là avec vous c'est midi et de présenter
mon histoire mon projet aussi parmi vous
qui n'a jamais eu une idée d'invention
une idée qui pourrait peut-être un jour
révolutionner que vous n'avez pas eu les
moyens de la concrétiser
la plupart du monde ont déjà eu cette
ambition là moi des cinq ans j'avais
cette ambition là c'était à travers des
outils à travers quand je regardais mon
papa bricoler c'était très simple et
avec des tournevis en plastique je
pensais pour voir peut-être un jour
évoluer le monde c'était très modestes
dans mon jardin
mais bon voilà j'avais que cinq ans
c'était qu'un début après vu arriver la
période de collège ou là on a d'autres
priorités c'est d'abord de faire ses
devoirs de réviser son cours des étés
donc voilà c'est keep calm fais tes
devoirs va pas plus loin
comme ça il n'y avait pas de question
qui se pose est sauf que heureusement
pour moi on va dire plutôt
malheureusement pour mes parents je vais
bien bricoler donc c'était démonter le
sèche-cheveux nommément le rasoir de mon
papa sans savoir parfois leur remontée
et s'était cette passion-là et au final
le constat que même en étant jeune
on pouvait et je pouvais réussir à faire
des choses moi même de mes propres mains
et ça ça a été un constat vraiment
marquant pour moi et finalement tout
tous ces problèmes que les grands en
montant en créant leur société et que -
j'ignorais les problèmes administratifs
tout cela je désignerai donc j'étais un
petit peu côté naïf mais qui m'a fait
aller très très vite très vite dans mes
démarches et du coup au fur et à mesure
j'ai pu développer à 13 ans j'ai déposé
mon premier brevet ça a été une vraie
aventure donc un premier brevet à l'inpi
c'était pour une machine à infuser le
thé c'est comme ça ça va pas ça
ressemble à rien mais c'était en fait un
bras robotique qui permettait de mettre
un sachet tessa calcul est le type de
thé la chaleur et au fus rabat
au bout d'un certain temps ça monte elle
le sachet de thé et on avait un bois
sont parfaitement aromatisées voilà
treize ans hélas out ici ça m'a conforté
dans le constat que même enfants
pouvaient faire des trucs sympa donc au
fur et à mesure des inventions des
brevets déposés je me suis éclatée en
parallèle de mon parcours scolaire ça
m'a pas empêché de faire un collège et
faire un bac comme tout le monde
vint le jour où un gros constat est
arrivé un constat qu'on a tous fait je
pense très tôt c'était le réveil il
fallait se réveiller le matin c'est
assez frustrant on n'arrive pas trop à
sortir de ça sa couette c'est l'une des
plus grosses décisions de nos journées
c'est quand même de sortir de votre
couette c'est assez dingue et cette
décision j'avais aujourd'hui mal à
prendre donc ça je la prenais pas ce jeu
là problème et ça dépend des jours je
m'étais dit pas pourquoi pas essayer de
trouver un nouveau moyen un nouveau mode
ils et elles sont et de ce fait la radio
est listé la lumière pourquoi pas
réveiller uniquement avec une odeur et
pourquoi pas en plus uniquement avec une
odeur qu'on aime bien et pour choisir un
petit peu comme les capsules
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé le réveil
olfactif sensor wake donc c'est assez
simple c'est cette boîte l'ap voyez ça
ça a vraiment la tête à rêver classique
sauf que ici on a une fente et on peut
insérer la cartouche de notre choix donc
par exemple placer l'odeur du bois donc
pour quelqu'un qui aime bien la nature
il va se réveiller uniquement en deux
minutes avec l'odeur du bois on a des
odeurs de colas des odeurs de bord de
mer il ya même pour les businessmen
l'odeur du dollar donc on a vraiment un
choix quasiment infinies on peut mettre
n'importe quel du moins un grand choix
de cartouches dans le réveil une
cartouche fait 60 réveille donc
contrairement aux machines à café le
tout est recyclable donc il n'y a pas de
problème concernant ceux ci les odeurs
sont sans solvant saint servais sans
composants organiques volatiles donc
c'est quelque chose de 100% sein est
quelque chose qui va vous teniez à coeur
pour développer donc ça s'est fait au
début dans le garage avec les fameuses
carte arduino pas besoin de savoir grand
chose et après au fur et à mesure ça a
bien marché ça a bien marché je suis
donné comme beaucoup c'était pendant les
révisions de bas que j'avais 17 ans et
j'ai participé un concours
de google le google cn ce faire et j'ai
eu la chance d'être le premier français
sélectionnés pour le google saillants de
fer que vous allez bientôt voir ici
voilà donc le google store de faire
c'est un concours international de
science qui réunit tous les jeunes
chercheurs et google je sélectionne
annuellement 15 projets pour venir dans
la silicon valley donc j'ai eu la chance
d'être le premier français à être
sélectionné par ce concours
ça m'a valu donc jacques grande joie
belle expérience faire entraîner pour
l'anglais c'est pas mal aussi mais
surtout surtout une reconnaissance de
cette invention une reconnaissance que
parfois on a du mal à avoir c'est bien
de faire une invention mais c'est aussi
bien de la faire partager et de
communiquer donc ça m'a valu un dîner
avec anne sophie lapix ça va lui aussi
de poser des questions à najat au petit
journal rencontré stéphane soumier donc
plein on va dire une vraie rampe de
lancement
une vraie croissance exponentielle grâce
à ce concours international de science
une expérience dingue c'est le mot est
aussi le meut m me mettre en condition
de me dire que même en étant jeune
on peut réaliser ses propres rêves on
peut aller au-delà du possible et que
une simple idée peut se transformer en
projets concrets plutôt sexy qui puisse
être communiqué et qui puisse peut-être
un jour modestement bien sûr changer le
quotidien des personnes et l'améliorer
voilà donc moi ce que j'invite
aujourd'hui les jeunes c'est on a la
chance en au 20e siècle les jeunes
peuvent démontrer qu'ils ont les moyens
de réussir
avant c'était plus dur c'est vrai que
dans l'histoire on attend on n'a pas
connaissance de beaucoup de jeunes qui
pouvaient imposer leurs idées maintenant
on a plein d'outils j'en parlais des
cartes vidéo maintenant avec internet
simple idée peut faire un buzz on en
voit avec des vidéos youtube des
youtuber et finalement donc je peux pour
conclure retenir une phrase qui m'a
beaucoup marqué ça a été un peu le
slogan du google vient de faire une
phrase
que j'ai dû répéter beaucoup de fois
devant la caméra c'est et sounthone tout
change au monde c'est ton tour de
changer le monde et je pense que au 21e
siècle c'est une phrase qui fait bel
écho et notamment si pour cette aide
aulas au delà des possibles c'est une
phrase ce cas tout son sens merci
beaucoup